[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
danke für die einladung das einzige was
wir jetzt leid tut ist dass ich nur
selten auf die übersetzerin blicken kann
wir haben im akademienprogramm ein
großprojekt über das lexikon der
gebärdensprache in hamburg und den den
jahren wo wir darüber beraten haben habe
ich unter anderem festgestellt dass man
auf diese weise was man eben als normal
sprechen oder gar nicht glaubt vielmehr
sagen kann als eben als normal
verzeihen sie als normal sprachlicher
längst nicht das sagen kann was man mit
der gebärdensprache zum ausdruck bringt
und insofern entgeht mir von dem was ich
jetzt heute abend sage wahrscheinlich
sehr viel aber ich kann nicht anders als
normal zu sprechen dass meine damen und
herren anthropologie und ethik etwas
miteinander zu tun haben ist in der
nachfolge kans zwar mehrfach bestritten
worden
aber es ist niemand geringeres als kant
selbst der uns grundsätzlich auf diese
verbindung verpflichtet wenn er im
letzten abschnitt der dialektik der
kritik der praktischen vernunft die
erwägung anstellt die natur könne uns
stiefmütterlich stiefmütterlich
behandelt haben
weil wir nicht in der lage sein unsere
einsichten unseren einsichten so zu
folgen wie wir es von einem vollkommenen
wesen erwarten würden nämlich wie von
selbst weil er dem vollkommenen wesen
das gute und richtige unmittelbar vor
augen steht dann macht kant die
notwendigkeit aufgrund eigener
bemühungen aufgrund eigener bemühungen
moralisch zu sein direkt abhängig von
der anthropologischen konstitution des
menschen es ist unsere unsere
menschliche unvollkommenheit die uns
nötigt der moral zu folgen
doch es ist nicht einfach nur die
unvollkommenheit die den menschen als
naturwesen kennzeichnet und die er durch
eigene anstrengungen auszugleichen hat
das ließe sich irgendwie von allen
lebewesen behaupten auch wenn es noch so
bequem ist bloß den kopf zu senken und
die mahlzeit schon angerichtet zwischen
den hufen vorzufinden
die mücken im freien flug aufzuschnappen
oder wie die made im speck inmitten der
nahrung waren und gut geschützt zu leben
alles leben dürfte auf seine weise
riskant und mühselig sein
und da hört es sich schon ziemlich
wehleidig an wenn der mensch über die
mängel klagt die er erst aufwendig durch
werkzeuge institutionen und
verhaltensregeln zu kompensieren hat um
so leben zu können wie er es gerne hätte
allein eigene wünsche zu haben ist ein
luxus der uns so vieles was wir
entbehren entschädigt die partiellen
menge in unserer konstitution können es
somit nicht sein die uns ethischen
ansprüchen aussetzen
ursächlich ist vielmehr das
missverhältnis zwischen einer
außerordentlichen begabung zur
erkenntnis zum wissen und zur einsicht
auf der einen und der eklatanten
schwäche daraus die angemessenen
praktischen konsequenzen zu ziehen auf
der anderen seite und da dieses
missverhältnis zu allem überfluss von
niemandem so stark empfunden wird wie
ausgerechnet vom menschen kann man schon
von einer besonderen last sprechen die
er zu tragen hat die rede von der
stiefmütterlichen behandlung oder was
oder von der mangelnden oder
mangelhaften ausstattung setzt also
bereits einen überschuss an fähigkeiten
voraus der ein bereits auf sie bezogenes
defizit empfinden lässt hier liegt der
pferdefuß der später terminologischen
gewordenen rede vom menschen als
mängelwesen bei gehen so sehr sie schon
durch platon vorgebildet und von herder
übrigens im anschluss an kant erneuert
worden ist arnold gehlen übersieht dass
die älteren konzeptionen dem menschen
einen weitreichenden erkenntnis
vorschuss gewähren in dessen licht ihm
seine mängel überhaupt erst als defizit
auffallen können in der erfahrung des
missverhältnisses zwischen
intellektuelle ausstattung und
praktischer umsetzung liegt
unzweifelhaft ein anthropologisches
kennzeichen des menschen und so muss man
es als ein elementares erfordernis
ansehen mit dem vom menschen selbst
empfundenen defizit so umzugehen dass es
zu seinem selbstverständnis passt was
dazu nötig ist mag uns nicht in jeder
hinsicht gefallen kann aber mit blick
auf unsere natur gleichwohl als
unvermeidlich angesehen werden wenn kann
zum beispiel die bemerkung macht der
mensch sei ein wesen das einen herrn
über sich braucht dann ist das eine
anthropologische feststellung aus der
man zum beispiel einen anthropologischen
grund für die unerlässlich kite einer
politischen organisation ableiten kann
dann nämlich wenn man die
weiterreichende schon bei platon zu
findende feststellung
trifft dass dieser herr niemand anderes
als ein mensch sein kann
das gilt auch für den fall dass sich
einzelne oder bestimmte
glaubensgemeinschaften in die
überzeugung hineinsteigern dieser herr
könne ein göttliches wesen sein denn
niemand der einen gott in die stellung
des über den menschen bestimmenden
herren zu bringen versucht kommt dabei
ohne menschen aus welche die wie immer
auch begriffen der herrschaft gottes
eben wie wir ja kennen stellvertretend
auszuüben suchen
somit ist es nicht nur im alltäglichen
leben sondern insbesondere auch in den
entscheidenden momenten ihres daseins
stets der mensch der sich als herr zu
erweisen hat so sehr er sich dabei auch
als stellvertreter gottes entweder gebet
gebärden oder aber fühlen mag wie man
sieht ist die problem konstellation in
der ethik der in der politik analog auch
im moralischen handelns hat der mensch
zu lernen sein eigener herr zu sein
dafür stehen die begriffe der
selbstbestimmung und der autonomie in
ihrem gebrauch wird nicht geleugnet dass
der mensch als naturwesen von vielen
abhängig ist und dass er in seiner not
wendig sozialen existenz auf
seinesgleichen und das was ihnen in
geschichte gegenwart und zukunft wichtig
ist rücksicht zu nehmen hat aber alles
das hat er in seiner erkenntnis
aufzunehmen und zum bestandteil seiner
eigenen einsicht zu machen die dann
allein den ausschlag darüber zu geben
hat was er mit gründen tut und in dem
was er tut versteht er sich ohne dabei
etwas an seiner bindung an die natur und
an die gesellschaft zu verlieren als
kulturelles wesen
das entspricht der zuordnung der ethik
zur jeweiligen kultur einer menschlichen
gemeinschaft die verbindung der internen
konditionen der selbstbestimmung mit den
externen der kultur tritt bei kant mit
aller wünschenswerten klarheit hervor
sie ist die grundkonstellation aber
einer jeden ethik die ihren namen
verdient ob jemand eine tugend oder eine
mitleids ethik vertreter gemeint er
könne das jeweils beste für eine
vielzahl von individuen situationen oder
handlungen ermitteln um danach zu
entscheiden was er zu tun hat in allen
diesen fällen wird eine einsicht zum
ausgangspunkt gewählt in der sich der
handelnde als eigenständig und somit als
herr seiner selbst zu begreifen hat aber
er kann dies nur als ein auf erkenntnis
und einsicht eingestelltes wesen das
eine langjährige erziehung sowie eine
gewöhnung an üblich keiten und
erwartungen benötigt um sich in seiner
umgebung auch nur seiner selbst sicher
zu sein
mit dieser kurzen beschreibung ist die
basale verbindung zwischen ethik und
anthropologie so denke ich immer hin
sichtbar gemacht
zugleich ist der ort der ethik im gefüge
von natur gesellschaft und kultur
angedeutet die anthropologische
grundlage stellt sicher dass sich die
ethik nicht von den sie tragenden
natürlichen und gesellschaftlichen
bedingungen löst ihre kulturelle
ortsbestimmung aber lässt keinen zweifel
daran dass sie selbst eine kulturelle
leistung darstellt deren besonderheit
darin zu sehen ist dass sie ihren sinn
stets erst in einem allgemeinen
bedeutungs rahmen unter wahrung
individueller ursprungs bedingungen
erhält symbiotisches und symbolisches
werden hier nur wirksam sofern sie von
individuen ausdrücklich individuell
aufgenommen geäußert und gebraucht
werden
das hört sich einfach an und ist durch
den alltäglichen sprachgebrauch in dem
wir natürlich gesellschaftliche und
kulturelle bereiche so als seien sie
selbst natürlich gegeneinander gesetzt
unterschieden
tatsächlich aber ist hier so gut wie gar
nichts selbstverständlich um sich dies
vor augen zu führen braucht man nur die
schöne pyramidal stufen folge aus natur
gesellschaft und kultur einer einzigen
frage nämlich der nach der stellung der
technik auszusetzen um ihre unerhörte
interne verbindung sichtbar zu machen
die frage lautet wohin gehört denn
eigentlich die technik zur natur zur
gesellschaft oder zur kultur stellt man
in rechnung wie groß der bogen ist den
die philosophie von der antike bis in
die jüngste gegenwart um die technik
macht müsste die antwort ein
achselzucken sein wohin soll sie schon
gehören und was liegt eigentlich an ihr
sie wird erfunden und gewählt weil es
die menschen sich bequemer machen wollen
sie mag zwar die wichtigtuer begeistern
die zieht vornehmlich aber das interesse
der trägen an vielleicht auch das
interesse der faulen aufsicht in ihr
wirksamere mittel finden weniger oder
gar nicht arbeiten zu müssen
gewiss wenn aus einer technischen
innovation etwas wird kann sie auch
anderen arbeitszeit ersparen dies aber
um den preis dass eben für diese
ersparnis aufs ganze gesehen
viele arbeiten müssen für dieses
ineinander
das gewiss noch keine dialektik
darstellt steht heute die doppelte
einsicht dass technik zwar in bestimmten
bereichen neue arbeitsplätze schafft sie
im ganzen aber vernichtet technik
besteht aus den angesammelten in
methoden und instrumenten aufgehobenen
arbeitsverträgen vieler
die erfunden und einmal erbracht den
nachfolgenden generationen in der tat
viel mühe ersparen
die zum einsatz kommende technik nimmt
denen die sie einfach gebrauchen aber
nicht nur einen mitunter beträchtlichen
anteil an eigener physischer anstrengung
sondern auch an intellektueller
eigenständigkeit an selbsterkenntnis und
eigenen risiko ab vielleicht wird damit
meine damen und herren verständlich
warum die technik bislang nur eine
geringe philosophische aufmerksamkeit
gefunden hat jahrtausende lang stand die
arbeit selbst nur in geringem ansehen
und da hat sich das mit dem anstieg der
nationalökonomie im achtzehnten und
neunzehnten jahrhundert änderte
gottseidank geriet die technik sogleich
in verdacht sie lenke den menschen von
sich selber ab denn sie schiebt sich in
der tat zwischen ihn und die lebendigen
dinge und kann daher als der ursprung
wenn ich das bösen für viele ist das so
wenn ich des bösen dann doch wenigstens
der entfremdung angesehen werden gewiss
die handvoll ernsthafter technik
philosophen die es immerhin gibt ich
erinnere an ernst cup oder ernst
cassirer würden dem entschieden und mit
besten gründen wie ich meine
widersprechen aber ausgerichtet hat das
denken dieser technik philosophen
bislang nur wenig obgleich die technik
das leben des menschen in einem
steigendem maße bestimmt die größe die
bedeutung der technik ist umso größer
ist das ärgernis ihrer missachtung die
ihr die philosophen entgegenbringen die
kollektive neurose die hier sichtbar
wird lässt das schlimmste befürchten
nämlich dass der mensch in der
verleugnung der technik vornehmlich
seiner selbsterkenntnis aus dem weg geht
aber keine angst meine damen und herren
um hier nicht gleich zum human oder
sozial pathologen zu werden wähle ich
ein randproblem aus und frage was denn
eigentlich die technik mit der ethik
verbindet das hat sie sich schnell
zeigen wird auch mit der anthropologie
zu tun
es ist aber vornehmlich auch deshalb
reizvoll weil die ethik mitsamt der von
ihr beherrschten kulturkritik nicht
selten größten wert darauf legt mit der
technik nichts zu tun zu haben oder sich
von ihr abzugrenzen
es versteht sich von selbst dass ich
meine antwort hier nur in form einer
kurzen skizze geben kann
im ersten schritt dieser skizze ist zu
zeigen dass es die technik ist durch die
sich die natur das ist jetzt auch
wirklich wichtig dass es die technik ist
durch die sich die natur in eine neue
form nämlich die kultur überführt
angesichts der seit der antike
festgeschriebenen unterscheidungen
zwischen natur und kulturelle leistung
sagen wir zwischen physis auf der einen
und tests auf der anderen seite die sich
bis heute zu einem vielfältigen
kaleidoskop von gegensätzen ausgewachsen
haben scheint dass ein nahezu
aussichtsloses unterfangen zu sein
gleichwohl bin ich überzeugt dass uns
die umfassenden einsichten in die
frühgeschichte des menschen in die
ursprungsgeschichte unserer kultur und
beginnend mit der steinzeit und gefolgt
von den großen zivilisationen im afro
eurasischen halbmond um ab 6000 etwa vor
christus sowie die einsichten in die
logik der kulturellen evolution eine
belastbare argumentative basis für den
er weiß der these geben können dass die
menschliche kultur selbst eine form der
natur ist die wesentlich erst durch
technik ermöglicht wird
zur these sie sehen das geht schneller
als das reden wir nur mit dem mund zur
these von der kultur als von der natur
gehört der nachweis dass technik der
menschen keineswegs nur äußerlich ist
sondern dass sie auch seine innere
physiologische sogar molekulare
organisation sowie seinen reflexiven
umgang mit sich selbst bestimmt das ist
den medizinern und psychologen schon
seit langem vertraut aber es bereit
es bereitet uns auch im alltäglichen
leben offenbar keine probleme unsere
extremitäten nach art von technischen
werkzeugen zu begreifen
die hand ist das modell für den hammer
den teller
die schale löffel oder die kelle mit der
die polizei und stoppt das von den
organen des kopfes steuerungs impulse in
den ganzen körper ausgehen oder dass wir
etwa das auge nach dem modell so wie wir
es heute können eines fotoapparats
darstellen macht deutlich dass wir auch
in der erklärung technischer prozesse
hinausgehen aus uns und dann eben
technische apparate nach physiologischen
leistungen untersuchen und genau
umgekehrt ich habe das hier in meinem
text an eine reihe von auch antiken
beispielen dargestellt vieles was im
körper geschieht dann nach art eines
eben in der jeweiligen kultur bekannten
technischen vorgangs begriffen werden
kann
das hat heute schon längst die
kabarettisten erreicht bei otto waalkes
nehmen sich die organe wechselseitig in
die pflicht auge an großhirn groß in der
nase und ohr
beide an großen und noch bevor das
großhirn weitere befehle geben kann
veranlasst das kleinhirn dass der mensch
die flucht ergriff also in kürze sehen
sie dass die selbstverständlich und das
ist das auch in uns nach einem technisch
nach einer technischen organisation
gearbeitet
wird kurz der körper wird seit
jahrtausenden wie bei hu mer aristoteles
oder insbesondere in lius berühmten
beispiel als eine soziale kooperative
verschiedenste organe begriffen dabei
muss man aus dem blickwinkel unseres
heutigen wissens sagen dass die
mechanistischen modelle der neuzeit sich
die maschinelle einsicht einheit des
körpers ein wenig zu einfach vorgestellt
haben
die organische integration aller
funktionen wie flexibles zusammenspiel
mit den konditionen ihrer umwelt die
besonderheit der sozialen interaktion
die leistungen der medialen
kommunikation und die tiefen struktur
der selbststeuerung von der molekularen
über die physiologische bis hin zur
effektiven semantischen und
intellektuellen ebene alles das wurde
von den mechanistischen modellen heillos
unterschätzt gleichwohl lehren uns die
ungleich komplexeren sich selbst
steuernden elektronischen gerätschaften
in welchem umfang auch leben und geist
des menschen technisch rekonstruierbar
sind wie ist es bei genauerem hinsehen
aber mit unseren reflexiven unseren
geistigen leistungen
die frage ist natürlich nicht leicht zu
beantworten viele glauben bis heute eine
antwort sei den menschen gar nicht
möglich und sie verweisen auf das
göttliche
ich glaube dass hier ein fall vorliegt
in dem sich der mensch ausnahmsweise
einmal unterschätzt er ernst damit macht
die funktionsweise unsere begriffe
ebenfalls nach dem modell zu beschreiben
dass bereits die etymologie des
begreifens also des b greifen des
zugriffs das in den griff bekommen es
bestimmt der kann beträchtlich wie ich
meine weiterkommen wir erkennen dass man
hier zumindest nicht auf unüberwindliche
hindernisse stößt entscheidend ist dass
die wir dies
wäre das begrifflichen vom bahn
vorschneller ontologische separation
befreien und ernsthaft daran gehen ihre
funktionale einbindung in den
einheitlichen kontext des lebens
erfassen hier geht es nebenbei bemerkt
auch um mehr technisches verständnis für
die integralen leistungen der natur
selbst erkennen und begreifen sind
zweifellos etwas höchst besonderes das
nicht durch schlichte reduktion erfasst
werden kann
wir haben hier etwas unglaublich
bewegliches etwas vollkommen neues und
zugleich gänzlich anderes das etwas
leistet für das es in der physischen
welt kein beispiel gibt
deshalb stellt sich bei den geistigen
leistungen auch so leicht die
assoziation zum göttlichen ein um nur
ein beispiel zu nennen mit dem begreifen
und im denken ist man augenblicklich
sowohl am anfang wie auch am ende der
welt ehe die techniker auch nur damit
begonnen haben das erste raumschiff zu
bauen aber es ist nicht nötig sich erst
das ganze des raumes oder derzeit
auszudenken schon die fähigkeit der
begriffe überhaupt etwas zu definieren
als etwas festzulegen und damit
identität auszusagen vollführt das
doppelte kunststück in einem akt
individuelles und universelles
auszusagen
beides gibt es so wie wir es denken
nirgendwo als physischen tatbestand aber
kein physischer tatbestand ist ohne sie
zu beschreiben
schon dieses da also das tor des
aristoteles dieses dazu sagen oder zu
zeigen ist ohne begriff der universelles
her nimmt um es auf dieses eine
individuum oder individuelle wie zum
beispiel diese flasche exemplarisch zu
konzentrieren
einzig
wir können diese wechselseitige
zuspitzung von individuellem und
universellen individualität und
universalität als das erstaunlichste im
unscheinbaren unseres alltäglichen
denkens und sprechens ansehen sollten es
aber für möglich halten dass wir dafür
eine erklärung finden
dazu muss man sich vielleicht nur die
mühe machen genauer zu beschreiben was
durch das dieses da im miteinander
verschiedener menschen erreicht werden
kann
dadurch wird es nämlich immerhin möglich
dass verschiedene menschen es wird
möglich dass verschiedene menschen an
einer aufgabe beteiligt sind deren
lösung auch unabhängig von ihnen durch
wieder andere individuen womöglich auch
unter ganz anderen umständen eine hilfe
sein kann
zwar können die insektenforscher sagen
das sei auch termiten und ameisen
möglich wenn sie aufgrund ihrer
instinktiven ausstattung zur
arbeitsteilung lösungen ohne jede
erkenntnis ohne bezug auf individualität
und universalität gelangen
was aber ist wenn von der lösung der
aufgabe so wie wir menschen sie und
stellen erwartet wird dass sie durch die
beiträge der nachfolgenden individuen
von generation zu generation nicht nur
verstanden sondern auch verbessert
werden kann
dann muss die lösung als solche
aufgefasst werden können so dass sie
nicht länger nur der lebens sicherung
der aktuell an ihr beteiligten
individuen dient sondern sagen wir der
kultur dient in der sich leben lässt
und was ist beim weniger zeit zur
verfügung steht so dass man nicht erst
auf den genetischen niederschlag von
erfolg und misserfolg warten kann
sondern die individuen ihrer aktuell
gemachten erfahrungen auch
duell an die nächste generation
weitergeben können oder erwartet wird
dass sich zumindest tun oder wenn für
möglich gehalten werden soll das sein
vortrag irgendeine erkenntnis vermittelt
die unmittelbar aufgenommen werden kann
das lässt sich durch den instinkt nicht
leisten tut mir leid da jedenfalls stoße
ich an meine grenzen und ich nehme an
dass sie das auch tun
und dann brauchen die individuen für
solche fälle nicht nur ein verständnis
von etwas das als dasselbe gesehen
werden kann und jeder sieht das anders
was uns jetzt hier gezeigt wird aber es
ist tatsächlich dasselbe was jedenfalls
mit blick auf das was hier übersetzt
wird von der übersetzerin gezeigt wird
das ist das eine das muss geleistet
werden für viele im augenblick aber eben
auch auf dauer sonst könnte man keine
gebärdensprache entwickeln und zugleich
gehört dazu ein begriff desjenigen der
das glaubt zu verstehen also mit dem
lösungsvorschlag wir unter den
bedingungen geistiger leistungen möglich
ist greifen wir auf das
selbstverständnis der beteiligten
individuen aus die in der lage sein
müssen sich selbst nach art eines dieses
da begreifen zu können
ein schlichteres modell wäre es die
besonderheit des denkens darin zu sehen
dass wir es selbst schon nach art eines
tätigen einstellen sign teilens und
ordnungs ansehen das formen bietet in
deren stoffliche sin denen stofflich es
in einer weise bestimmt wird in der er
sich und das ist dann der begriff um die
man nicht herumkommt stofflich es in
einer weise begreift in der es sich
mitteilen lässt
so erscheinen begreifen und denken als
eine form vorausschauender organisation
von handlungen im sozialen raum die es
erlauben sich
jetzt vor einem geschehen über dessen
voraussetzungen dessen ablauf und dessen
mögliche folgen zu verständigen
vielleicht simuliert der intellekt eben
das was in einer geordneten folge von
tätigkeiten kooperation ermöglicht so
dass man ihn in seiner präsenten
verständlichkeit durch viele selbst
bereits als eine form socio technische
kooperation im zustand der simulation
bezeichnen können so gesehen könnte man
die alte platonische unterscheidung
zwischen göttlicher idee und sinnlich
präsenten dingen in eine ziemlich genaue
veranschaulichung der leistungen des
geistes übersetzen denn die idee bietet
das uneingeschränkte verständnis eines
sachverhalts der stets nur unter den
üblichen lokalhistorischen
einschränkungen vergegenwärtigt oder gar
neu geschaffen werden kann
so kann das selbe überall und jedes mal
anders verstanden werden das wird jetzt
hier in meinem text noch im einzelnen
ausgeführt und ich versuche vor allem
deutlich zu machen was dann in dem buch
im ansatz geschildert ist und was ich
deswegen auch wegen der nahezu 6 und der
zeitung jetzt hier nicht noch einmal auf
vier der fünf seiten verlängern muss
dass das bewusstsein selbst als ein
organ der mitteilung verstanden werden
kann
und wenn wir dies dann zugrunde legen
ergibt sich zumindest die hoffnung dass
wir das geistige nach einem modell
begreifen dass vor allem natürlich ein
soziales modell ist ein kooperatives
soziales modell das aber immer sich an
etwas mit bestimmten mitteln und formen
abarbeitet und das insofern ohne technik
nicht verstanden
gesetzt meine damen und herren das
gelänge den hier skizzierten beweis für
die soziopathische verfassung des
menschlichen bewusstseins zu führen wäre
es auch möglich einen engen zusammenhang
zwischen ethik und technik aufzuweisen
und dies könnte in einer weise geschehen
die nicht den verdacht auf sich zieht
der ethik einen ausnahmezustand
zuzuschreiben sobald wir sie als
technisch als immer auch technisch
qualifizieren
die überlegung brauchte auch nicht den
vorwurf auf sich zu ziehen
sie wehrte die ethik ab weil sie ihr nur
einen technischen status zuerkennt wenn
alles bewusste alles geistige immer auch
zu den techniken gehört durch die sich
der mensch seinen kulturellen run
erwirbt ihn zugleich erhält sichert und
vielleicht auch erweitert wird die ethik
keineswegs ab sondern vielleicht sogar
aufgewertet in ihrem elementaren bezug
zu unseren eigenen strategien der
lebensbewältigung genießen denn sie wird
in den zusammenhang der steigerung so
könnte man auch sagen der besten kräfte
des menschen gestellt zu denen und
einmal die potenzen des bewusstseins und
des geistes gehören die aber ließe sich
der beweis für die innere technische
verfassung der ethik führen sehr leicht
und ohne besonderen aufwand wenn es nur
um die das ist jetzt natürlich ein
rhetorisches nur nur um die antiken
trugen tätigen ginge sie sind ohnehin
auf das jeweils beste in eine handlungs
lage gerichtet das beste dass jedes
individuum nach seinen besten kräften
unter den bedingungen die dazu am besten
passen anzustreben hat es sind und darf
nicht ihr unschätzbarer vorzug tätigen
der individuellen tüchtigkeit der
jeweiligen art e
jeder und jede unter beweis zu stellen
hat tapferkeit um nur ein beispiel zu
nennen ist die tugend die dazu dient den
krieg auf optimale weise zu führen oder
in der neueren demokratischen fassung
wie sie keineswegs erst durch richard
schröder oder so vorgeführt wird sondern
wie sie im lach es bei platon
nachzulesen ist tapferkeit als die
zivilcourage die man braucht um in der
versammlung mutig sein wort auch gegen
viele widerstände zu machen
da wird die tapferkeit bereits als seine
zivilcourage definiert und ist natürlich
unter diesen bedingungen immer auch
gebunden ja an die durchsetzung des
bestens des besten unter den bedingungen
unter denen man handelt
das könnte ich ihnen jetzt noch im
einzelnen vorführen aber ich will das
jetzt nicht an den anderen tugenden
zeigen und ich habe jetzt hier auch noch
ein kapitel über nietzsche mit
untergebracht der das besondere hat sich
zwar für alles zu interessieren was das
überhaupt im kulturellen zusammenhang
gibt nur die ethik das heißt sie die
hätte kritisiert er nur die technik für
die hat er kein auge für die ist er
gewissermaßen blind
da braucht's parolen ergibt ständig zum
apotheker fährt mit der eisenbahn quer
durch europa spielt auf einem
technischen instrument wie dem klavier
aber irgendwie fällt ihm die
besonderheit dieser geräte mit denen er
lebt und mit denen er es der erste mit
einer schreibmaschine schreibt fällt ihm
nicht auf und deswegen finden wir nichts
aber das interessante ist und das wird
in der überlegung kurz vorgetragen dass
er immerhin in seiner kritik der ethik
noch die möglichkeit einräumt neue
tugenden vorzusehen und diese neuen
tugenden die er deutlich macht durch den
begriff der souveränität
interessanterweise und die dadurch
definiert sind dass hier ein mensch so
souverän ist dass er nie gesagt das wird
meistens übersehen versprechen darf also
er hat sich schon durch sein verhalten
das vertrauen vieler erworben so dass
ihm auch das nächste versprechen
abgenommen wird der macht sich durch
diese tugend die nietzsche ihm immerhin
zugesteht berechenbar und das ist denke
ich ein sehr aufschlussreicher hinweis
dass tugend dasjenige ist was uns
berechenbarer macht und wer braucht man
dann zum auf weiß eines technischen
implikation einer tugend die selbst
nietzsche immerhin zugesteht glaube ich
nicht zu sagen doch meine damen und
herren das experiment um kurzes für eine
innere technische verfassung der ethik
hat darin zu bestehen die ethik die sich
grundsätzlich gegen jede technische
rationalität zu sperren scheint auf ihre
verträglichkeit mit der ethik zu prüfen
diese moralphilosophie ist die kritische
ethik immanuel kants und ich würde
sozusagen vor meinem thema versagen wenn
ich nicht dort auskenne und fragte wie
es denn mit blick auf das verhältnis von
ethik und technik bei kant eigentlich
steht in der form seiner imperative
scheint ganz die sukzessive entfernung
des moralischen denkens von einer
technischen und pragmatischen
rationalität begrifflich vor zu zeichnen
indem er drei typen von imperativen
unterscheidet von denen erst der dritte
typus spezifisch moralisch genannt
werden kann
kant unterscheidet bekanntlich und jetzt
kommt ein bisschen pro seminar
technische imperative technische
imperative
ihr fehlt im rahmen der grundlegung der
mit der physik der sitten dieser
ausdruck technische imperative welche
die mittel vorschreiben welche die ziele
welche durch die ziele vorgegeben sind
wenn ich hier einen wissenschaftlichen
vortrag halten will muss ich ebenfalls
nach meinem selbstverständnis etwas
neues sagen
das ziel des vortrags also schreibt die
mitte eben der einer innovativen aussage
wie ich es verstehe vor dramatische
imperative in denen ein allgemeines ziel
etwa das seines guten aus commons oder
eines zufriedenen zustands im blick sind
sind die zweite stufe für sie für diese
pragmatischen pragmatischen imperative
hat man ebenfalls die geeigneten mittel
auszuwählen
wenn ich gesund bleiben möchte habe ich
mich um eine mäßige lebensweise zu
bemühen hier liegt die besonderheit
nicht nur in der größeren reichweite der
ziele und des größeren spielraums
tauglicher mittel sondern vor allem auch
darin dass die auswahl der geeigneten
mittel auch einfluss auf die ziele haben
kann
gleichwohl sind auch die pragmatischen
imperative im grunde technischer natur
nur sie tragen der komplexität
lebensweltliche entscheidungsprozesse
rechnung hier müssen mittel und ziele
oder zwecke im kontext wahrgenommen
werden so dass eine wechselseitige
korrektur zur klugheit gehört die in
pragmatisch zu bewältigenden lebenslagen
erforderlich ist
am technischen charakter dieser
orientierungs und entscheidungswege ist
so meine ich jedenfalls nicht zu
zweifeln und mir liegt an der
feststellung dass diese größere
reflexion spannweite der pragmatischen
imperative durchaus unter den titel der
ethik gehört hier also hat kant nicht
die geringste scheu die technik ins
zentrum der ethischen reflexion zu
stellen im strengen sinn als moralisch
gilt kann jedoch nur wie könnte es
anders sein der kategorische imperativ
und diese freistellung gegenüber dem
technischen und dem pragmatischen
handlungsfeld wird von kant mit einer
grundsätzlichkeit vollzogen dass man
sich als kann die amish und ziemlich
warm anziehen muss um ihr tatsächlich
etwas technisches entdecken zu wollen
also auf am kant kongress würde ich sehr
behutsam zu argumentieren versuchen und
ich sage das gleichwohl als theoretiker
der sich im wesentlichen im wesentlichen
dem ansatz ganz verpflichtet weiß und
die frage ist ob nicht durch die
sonderstellung dass die ethik
auszeichnenden kategorischen imperativs
jede überlegung ethik und technik zu
verbinden der boden entzogen wird
damit müsste es auch als unerheblich
erscheinen auf die technischen
implikationen der technischen und
pragmatischen imperative zu verweisen
denn im kategorischen imperativ wird
jede technisch wird jeder technischen
erwägung eine riegel vorgeschoben
ja man könnte sagen dass der
kategorische imperativ das kategorische
verbote einer übertragung technischer
überlegungen auf moralisches verhalten
zum ausdruck bringt das sage ich nur
damit sie sehen wie schwer die aufgabe
ist die jetzt im letzten teil meines
vortrags vor mir nicht tatsächlich ist
es so und es ist nicht anders denn noch
ist nicht zu übersehen dass der
kategorische imperativ kann's technische
elemente enthält die schweden die man
schwerlich los als beiläufig bezeichnen
kann
wenn ich sie abschließend benenne
geschieht das in dem bewusstsein selbst
noch nicht ganz genau zu wissen welche
schlussfolgerungen für das verhältnis
von ethik und technik dann in einer
systematischen fassung der überlegung zu
ziehen sind bekannt in der wichtigsten
fassung
seines kategorischen imperativ sagt
handle so dass die menschheit in der
person eines jeden anderen niemals bloß
als mittel sondern immer auch als zweck
gelten kann
dann ist sie haben das ja gehört die
technik in der unterscheidung zwischen
zweck und mittel offensichtlich sie ist
also hier eingeschlossen in die
formulierung und zugestanden ist auch
dass sich die dimension des gebrauchs
als mittel niemals ausschließen es
niemals bloß als mittel sagt er mit
aller klarheit dass sich gar nicht
vermeiden kann jemanden als mittel zu
meinen zwecken zu gebrauchen übrigens
sein lieblingswort bekannt um nur ein
beispiel zu nennen sie als meine zuhörer
sind im augenblick das mittel das mir
dazu dient unter dem anspruch eines
öffentlichen vortrags meine gedanken zu
sortieren dass daraus eine systematisch
abgesicherte so dass daraus eine
systematisch abgesicherte philosophische
einsicht werden kann ich wüsste nicht
was daran schlecht sein sollte außer dem
vortrag selbst vielleicht und es steht
dem kategorischen imperativ nicht
entgegen sie also meine damen und herren
sind das mittel für mich um mit meinem
vortrag ein stückchen weiter zu kommen
andererseits bin ich aber das wäre jetzt
konsequent wenn oder fährt ebenfalls
fahrlässig finde ich mich gänzlich aus
nehmen würde
andererseits bin ich aber auch für sie
ein mittel zum zweck nämlich zur
erweiterung ihrer erkenntnis
möglicherweise auch nur
aber was heißt hier nur ein mittel zur
unterhaltung und zur ablenkung von
ernsteren fragen vielleicht bin ich für
den einen oder anderen am ende nur das
mittel zu der erkenntnis dass es sich
nicht lohnt sich philosophische vorträge
anzutun
doch wie immer ihre einsichten auch sein
mögen der gebrauch den sie als hörer von
mir als dem referée
machen verstößt nicht gegen den
kategorischen imperativ das kann ich
ihnen jedenfalls versichern
also erst um das mindeste zu sagen die
technik in der anwendung des
kategorischen imperativs gegenwärtig
ausgeschlossen werden kann sie damit auf
keinen fall wenn sie aber gar nicht
eliminiert werden kann
was bedeutet das dann für die moralität
des kategorischen imperativ einem ich
selbst überzeugende antwort habe ich wie
gerade schon angedeutet noch nicht aber
es gibt hinweise die man so denke ich
als fingerzeige werden kann
erstens der kategorische imperativ also
das verfahren mit dem ich meine maximen
prüfe ist ein instrumentarium zur
widerspruchsfreien ermittlung meiner mir
wichtigen ziele
er ist ein teil einer methodischen
überlegung die man selbst als technik zu
einem kritischen test bezeichnen kann
man kann auch sagen der kategorische
imperativ selbst ein instrumentarium der
verlor 2 der imperativ prüft maximen
das sind wie ganz sagt subjektive ich
neige eher dazu zu sagen individuelle
grundsätze die jeder handelnde brauchte
er sich nach einem sichten richten denn
alles ausdrücklich menschliche handeln
folgt der einschätzung von situationen
und motiven sowie von eigenen und
fremden kräften und ist daher auf regeln
gegründet kant geht also davon aus dass
jeder in allen ihm wichtigen handlungs
lagen seine individuellen grundsätze hat
und wer moralisch handeln will hat diese
grundsätze nach dem kategorischen
imperativ zu prüfen
das ist soweit der stoff für das
positive
aber warum sagt kant maxime weil er mit
den ethikern aller zeiten insbesondere
denen des altertums unterstellt dass es
um tugenden geht also letztlich um
tüchtig keiten in denen jeder sein
bestes geben will maximen die
unterstellen dass man seine sache
möglichst gut machen will
also gilt auch hier was sich über die
technische grund ist position der
antiken tugend lehrern gesagt habe
drittens die kritische prüfung steht im
dienste der autonomie des individuums
alle bemühungen um die moralität des
handelnden ist ein akt der
selbstbestimmung kann dass der erste der
diesen begriff gebraucht und kann in
deren vollzug selbst als ein mittel zur
emanzipation des individuums und zur
wahrung von dessen eigenständigkeit
verstanden werden also erfüllt die
prüfung eine nicht anders als technisch
zu nennende funktion in der kulturellen
entfaltung des individuums und damit der
menschheit die in der person eines jeden
einzelnen zu sichern ist viertens in der
ethik setzt jeder seine eigenen ziele
und in ihr sucht er seine person als wie
kant sagt als zweck an sich selbst zu
wahren
sie ist in dieser stellung also selbst
gewiss kein mittel zur vervollkommnung
der menschheit
das liefe auf eine restlose technische
einbindung in einen bereits bestehenden
oder von anderen verfügten kulturellen
zweck hinaus dem das individuum dann
gänzlich unterworfen sein könnte auch
wenn sich das individuum selbst in
seiner unvollkommenheit damit bescheiden
kann das alles was es an gutem selbst
nicht erreicht
unter den bedingungen der menschheit
aber vielleicht
eines tages erreicht werden kann darf
kein selbsternannter oder von anderen
vorgesetzte funktionär der menschheit
auftreten der das individuum zum mittel
an diesen zwecken degradierte damit eben
dieser zweck der kultur erreicht werden
kann jeder einzelne hat es sich als hat
sich selbst als den zweck zu begreifen
auf den alle anderen mittel zu laufen
aber und das ist mein letzter punkt zu
wenig das individuum einen bereits
bestehenden ziel der kultur oder gar der
technik unterworfen ist kann dies
gleichwohl unter den konditionen der
technik begriffen werden und ich hoffe
eines tages sagen zu können muss
unter den konditionen von technik
begriffen werden können einer technik
die unter diesen bedingungen auch die
besondere kunst erfährt im ganzen also
nicht nur in ihren mitteln sondern auch
ins ihren zielen grundsätzlich der
kritik der vernunft unterworfen wird zu
können
also steht auch hier die technik in
einer nicht nur unverzichtbaren sondern
herausgehobenen positionen und in kants
geschichtsphilosophie hat sich jedes
individuum damit zu trösten jedes auch
die besten auch die erfolgreichsten
damit zu trösten dass es selbst gewiss
nicht alles erreichen kann
aber die perfektion eines individuell
und zu länglichen wollens kann wie kann
sagt immerhin in der gattung erreicht
werden so findet die ethik dann bei ihm
doch einen platz in der geschichte in
der sich jeder selbst als ein mittel zu
einem sagen wir erlösen und befreienden
zweck begreifen kann sofern er sich
ethisch bestimmt so verbinden sich
jedenfalls nach einer vorläufigen
einschätzung am ende ethik und technik
doch zu einem umfassenden
welche schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen
könnte kann ich vielleicht wenn sie
interessiert in der diskussion noch
sagen ich will es jetzt bei diesen
bemerkungen belassen und es tut mir leid
dass ich auf dieses blöde beispiel von
zweck und mittel bei publikum und
referenten gekommen bin wo ich doch an
den übersetzerinnen ein viel besseres
beispiel gehabt hätte dass sie das
mittel sind damit wir etwas wenn wir
eben taub sein sollten etwas verstehen
können vielleicht sogar genau das und
zugleich aber die person die da steht
zwar eine funktion erfüllt aber zweck an
sich selber ist das ist der sinn der
kantischen rede
und ich hoffe dass ich habe zeigen
können dass dies nicht ausschließen muss
dass die technik dabei eine rolle spielt
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit